first probably the most important thing
is that we actually query whether or not
all the images have been loaded if we
don't do this little step where we query
this dot fully loaded then what's going
to happen is you can go through your
draw function trying to draw image data
that hasn't actually been loaded into
memory of course you'll just see nothing
on the screen but it's generally a good
practice to let the entire thing load
before you try to start working on it
next we actually loop through all of the
layers and for each one determine
whether or not it's actually a tile
layer remember we can actually get
object layers from the tiled setup so we
need to make sure that we're only
rendering tile layers from there we
actually create a convenient handle to
the data array and then we walk through
all the tile ids inside of that data
array if it equals zero we go ahead and
continue on because no tile needs to be
drawn there if it's not zero we go ahead
and grab the packet information for this
tile